[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا اعيد واكرر هذه الصور التي
نشرها الجيش السوداني من داخل مقر القياده
العامه حيث عناصر الجيش موجودين داخل مبنى
القياده العامه وطبعا للتذكير بان القتال
الاساسي ينحصر الان بمحيط القياده العامه
اذا هذه الصور من داخل مبنى القياده
العامه للجيش
وطبعا
تثبت وتبرهن سيطره الجيش على الداخل على
المبنى الرئيسي في الخرطوم اذا الاشتباكات
للتفكير هي دائره بمحيط هذه النقطه بمحيط
مبنى القياده العامه ما زالت حتى الساعه
وهنا هذه الصور تؤكد وجود الجيش داخل مبنى
القياده العامه
وان شاء الله هنعيد عيدين اخواننا العيد
عيدين والله والله العيد عيدين الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
[موسيقى]
اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
العيد العيد
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات